we've got a voicemail that is a little
bit different today sometimes the voice
mails or trolls and sometimes their
policy related we're doing something a
little different today here's a nice
little voice mail that came in at 219 to
david p very risk recently let's take a
listen together i just wanted to say
that I think you're hella sexy david
pakman oh my gosh just take your shirt
off you yeah uh what do you think about
this Pat amis love david pakman I don't
know that there's a place on the show
necessarily for me to take my shirt off
it would have to be created uh and I
don't know that it would fit naturally
with the themes of the show well if
you've seen the 2017 david pakman show
calendar there is a couple comic strips
in there yeah where david implements a
new dress code and decides to take a
shirt off that's right i have the
calendar here and i'm trying to remember
with what month that is in the calendar
by the way is selling now like hotcakes
and they're there this is all original
art by dan burke and there is one I
don't think we have the image for you to
pull up Pat and I think it's sort of
towards the end uh yes here it is so the
September 2017 I know you won't really
be able to see this but also sort of
hold it up there's a cartoon in which I
come in and I'm very scantily clad and
rachel is very surprised at what I'm
wearing this is the set September 2017
comic strip and I like Pat allowing a
seamless segue into mentioning that the
2017 cartoon coloring book theme david
pakman show calendar is available at
david pakman.com slash calendar 17 it's
really the place to see me shirtless if
that's your priority and i know for many
people it isn't and that's totally okay
uh but this is the place to do that I'm
sure the caller will order at least one
of them having a yeah I hope that they
will uh if you want just the calendar
david pakman.com slash calendar 17 you
can get it autographed or not
autographed and if you want the calendar
for free you can also get it with a
yearly membership signed or unsigned at
david pakman.com slash calendar 17 and
of course is that we set a record by the
13th
of this month of November we already had
more new members then we have ever had
previously an entire calendar month in
just the first 13 days and I don't know
how high the numbers will climb but you
betcha that I will be reporting to you
at the end of the month how we do if you
would like a discounted membership and
you we want people involved at any level
I voted 17 all one word all lower case I
voted 17 is a coupon code that you can
use at david pakman.com slash membership
to get a forty percent discount off of
your membership i hope you will do that
and after doing it i hope you'll join us
on the bonus show where I I have some
really really great stories today and
will speak to you then